blugh activity is widespread in nearly
every state this morning but an FDA
panel meeting today is ready to finalize
next year's vaccine that will give
manufacturers the six to nine months
they need to prepare more than 150
million doses to fight the flu
while the vaccine is the first line of
defense a CDC study found that this year
it's been only 30 36 percent effective
our doctor Tara Narula went inside a lab
where researchers are working on a
universal flu vaccine tara good morning
doc tell us the good news good morning
Alex
the flu vaccine is the only routine
vaccinations people need to take every
year which is why scientists around the
world have been searching for decades
for a universal flu vaccine one that
targets all the strains of the flu virus
and will last a lifetime it is a very
difficult goal it is sort of the Holy
Grail Peter Polizzi and his team of
microbiologists at Mount Sinai Hospital
in New York have been working almost
exclusively for five years on finding
the holy grail of flu prevention and
they believe they're close it is right
now in phase one
people are being as we speak being
vaccinated with this vaccine and that is
the first step in getting it approved
how long do you think before we see
phase two or phase three I think it
should be faster than ten years ten
years may seem like a long time but it
takes understanding why the flu is
unique compared to other viruses like
measles or mumps the virus is changing
constantly which is why we have to get a
new vaccine every year but there are
parts of the virus which are staying
constant think of the influenza virus as
coded with little mushrooms each with a
head and a stem the current vaccines
only target the head but that's the part
that easily changes or mutates into
different strains making vaccine
effectiveness challenging but scientists
discovered that the stem remains
relatively the same therein lies the
holy grail target the unchanging part
this is really from an idea that was
developed on the bench in two clinical
trials in basically eight years Florian
Kramer
is leading the clinical trials in humans
this is called a bio bubble we can
prepare vaccines eat viruses that are
then going into manufacturing and can
then be used in in human clinical trials
they're also using chicken eggs to grow
their vaccines the difference to what
you would buy in the supermarket is just
that they have an embryo in them it's a
method of vaccine development used for
over 70 years
the eggs are injected with strains of
the flu virus incubated for a few days
and harvested to prepare the vaccine how
many doses a vaccine can you get from
one egg so typically you would get one
to three doses of vaccine break with at
least 97 pediatric deaths this flu
season is the worst in nearly a decade
do you feel like the recent changes that
we've been seeing in terms of the
epidemics and the pandemics and this
season are driving the research is he
unfortunately it is worse than what we
have seen over the last 10 years almost
clearly this is more motivation and we
really want to try to find something
which eliminates this disease this
severe flu season has lent urgency to
the search for a one-and-done flu shot
but the central issue now is federal
funding while the National Institutes of
Health is funding Mount Sinai's work
some researchers believe with more funds
we could see a universal flu vaccine in
less than five years I like it in peace
when you said ten years seems like a
long time yes it does it seems like a
long time but you're saying when you
really put it into perspective not so
long not so long I mean science tends to
move at a slow pace but I agree that
with more funding hopefully we'll get
there quicker I hope so too graph is
still very helpful to understand it
thanks that was great